good evening welcome to the you prefer
meeting for this evening before we start
I will read out the emergency procedures
please note this meeting will be audio
recorded simply be required to evacuate
the building would you please leave the
room both door for estate staircases
behind us where we all know please hold
both raise your hand rails in case of
stairs are wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use a step they please allow
the others back to the room before they
go to the fire escape door where they
can be given assistance our assembly
point is in the public power Parker
inside the Civic sweet please do not
delay click your evacuation collect any
belongings please do not return the
building until compania permission by
council star apologies for absence we
have from counselors chris black George
Gibson and John Mason he not members
attending 33 caster
and can I take minutes meeting held in
life that you'd be on to record events
that took place a griever thank you any
declarations of interest all right I
don't know five on the agenda then I'm
sorry what should hundred more respect
with regards to the CSP there's
representation guessing myself for now
we'll be attending okay right lady who
is in the black jacket don't tribe who
has compiled the reporter with assume or
read this evening I'll start very
briefly doing is there any areas that
you'd like I mean we've read the report
I suggested that you would like to
elaborate on that you know haven't been
fully covered with with your words mm no
I'm gonna say beyond cavity take
undertaking aid internal review on the
presence that we are we used for
complaints logging and monitoring due to
the information coordinator room during
the year designed so that an opportunity
to that so we've slightly changed we
haven't replaced that post and so the
monitoring and managing all the
complaints from the follow-up of them is
not being undertaken by the leadership
support team which is the news team that
it's made up for me pas
actually an undertaking that wrong have
you found this kids a more accurate
assessment or is it just a more
streamlined way of doing doing the
reporting and it's a good streamlined
way of doing reporting and as well of
following up because you know whether in
its place now if somebody hasn't pull it
up on a complaint and they haven't
replied in a timely manner then there's
quickly picked up and it's ensure that
that happens well there are some other
areas i'm sure some of you colleagues
would like to touch on and so if anybody
would like to start off oh hey mr.
chairman it's nice to see the high
number of companies rather than
complaints which i think is a good thing
we've got the numbers of the complaints
and the compliments and the comments not
the largest seen as a percentage of the
hull so we don't know whether for
instance is a hundred 407 complaints my
face it reverses in % e problem or s
weathers and number yeah just give us a
better picture yeah I mean these are the
formal complaints that we get to us that
get escalated and then we obviously goes
with this woman complaints process so we
do any comments continental feedback
that we get is always logged into my
pocket back off your systems anyway but
it becomes a bit so complicated but you
know I complain to the complaint and we
deal with in a specific kind of way make
sure it's lot and it's followed up and
then it but you know the person is
satisfied at the end of it as a percent
as a percentage anyone have looked to
break that down into queries or service
areas but that's quite quite I would say
that it's quite a big job to do that
that kind
we could look at doing that yes Billy
Graham become you know comments and Janu
semen a flea a feeling therefore it is
whether it's timber same one I don't
know obviously I wouldn't mind doing
some some work around that John and how
some of the complaints really directed
to other bodies but they're just
funneled through the council such as bus
services on photography will always if
it isn't the service that we're
providing them again we will always look
it we're always trying to monitor it but
we would we would obviously try to find
out how they can raise that complaint
through the right channels then because
we can't control the services being
provided so we will always try to put in
through the right channels they'll often
get to our customer services set depart
then you know who will then try and help
as much as they care if it's somebody
coming into reception they should get
the same response for us so we try to
push them through because if the mainly
can play the thing we want to do is make
sure that it gets rectified as quickly
as possible this this formal complaint
process takes you through an escalation
and for all organizations who have a
waiver somebody to love that so there's
a filtering process of filtering process
we try to do that
go Jack if I may show me if I'm wrong
the reassurances put the public
residence in general with the fear of
crime etc do we measure that if so how
how is that fed back you know like if
you've got so now do you measure that in
terms of high-volume areas like volume
if there is a crime we've seen things
happen for you for example within the
town center the late nights lots of
rumors go around I don't see a lot
challenging the fear of what's going on
you with me there are you sure yeah I
mean as I say this formal complaint
procedure will will will deal with
anybody who is going to make a complaint
against a favor of the council's a
policy that they're not I don't like
obviously there's other there's other
processes in which to deal with those
sorts of things like Miss beans better
contact process that what you're saying
is that will get channel through to the
department that will be responsible for
that and it's up to them for their
statistics of amount of feedback read
that back where this this is about
somebody making a formal perform
complaint to escalate everything if
someone asks for a service or they make
a comment to us it is logged into our
back office systems so we can get lots
of information out of that but this is a
formal complaint process that somebody
has wanted to talk to follow and about
the services of the council
policies and so that's that's what this
is recording in that way you don't build
from there to say that we ought to be
here are the exercise / speak to relay
those fears you know we we will do
lesson to learn them that's something
that came out the executive and asked
for a breakdown of if there's common
complaints that coming in and we do look
at that as a staff and we do look at
that assistant directors now we'll be
feeding that into our meeting that will
be having is to look at where those
common issues that have been coming up
and feed that back into the service
areas i'd be down to the assistant
directors to take those back into the
service areas and to look at those so if
we've had a lot of conference about
certain area could be crying it could be
the contracts not performing we've had a
failure in a certain area then that
should be picked up and that should be
dealt with by the assistant director but
the end the person will be contacted
individually through this this
complaints procedure where it gets
escalated up through through the young
through the authority gonna die just
picked up or home on one thing you said
there's on where you've talked about the
involvement of the assistant directors
now how how regularly though do they
meet to discuss these figures and do
they involve portfolio holder as well in
this or or how does it operate now so
we're just reviewing that process now so
what we aim to do we used to have what's
called a custom axes and consultation
group meeting that used to involve heads
of service and
to have a representative on that number
we decide let's do it through the
assistant directors and that will be
reporting to throw we haven't quite
decided how regularly yet we meet
regularly or make every week so if
there's any issues that will be
escalated up through these two directors
but the quarterly reports come out so we
will be looking at them at least
quarterly if not before then if there's
any issues so we're going to get the
leadership support team to do some of
that looking at the lessons learned and
taking some that information and then
highlighting some of that too or so that
we've been proactive in looking at it
not just waiting for the report so they
should be able to see if there's any
common things that are coming through
and they should be highlight from that
participants you can be working quite
closely and it's at least a big fed
through to the executive will it all or
to the portfolio whole industry yes that
there that's been asked for for the next
quarter which would be not tougher side
very good evening Thank You them and two
questions actually hopefully both quite
quick there's a separate column for
racial incident and it statistics going
about 2011 but wait they're limiting
inning is that against council staff
what in terms of that right says that
that would be a chore p thanks against
people at the council being was it that
would be any DNA and wheels relies to be
called those separately with that not
and this time just I work out what's all
complained about yeah yeah but I mean is
this this table as you can see has been
has been there quite water and we beat
weeping we've been monitoring and
managing those those those sorts of
complaints so at the time that this was
done and his father's
the one that sort of set this up it was
you know we were told what they would
like to look at lunch monitor and and so
that at the time i'm guessing as a
reason why that was there and we've just
always that that is except for kali
because we've been asked to do that so
I'm not really a specific reason why
after I'm not sure and then the other
question as well is there a way that
perhaps it is not necessary now by the
future we can know how these compliments
comments and complaints of the inputs
the cancer what the most popular method
is whether it's fire forms online
picking up the phone and phone in the
council just so proposed really to gauge
how proactive the council are in
requested people to make complaints or
companies really I think it'd just be
quite interesting to see how people
doing it yeah but there is a telephone
here's our codes that they're just doing
it online for their arch you've still
traditionally a lot to pick up phone and
actually speak to somebody yeah or you
know they quite straight anonymously
just type it out nothing just be quite
interesting see if there's a pattern
yeah yeah they create that is logged the
messaging the way that they contact us
but that can go in on to the monitoring
in fullness i stake in the time it's
like interesting to see if it changes
over time or yeah see the council do
wrong that's it thank you sir yeah very
good boy night because I was picking up
on the racial instance yes there I'm a
total complaint categories 11 of 11
you've got council level policy in the
same column complaints against council
or holiday yeah and they are slightly
different
just wondered whether we could have
those split anybody else feels about
that because so I complaints against
government policy is different to
complaints against Alexander yeah that
may not be the best wedding so what will
have lines see what those complaints
actually are have a breakdown of what
what they see if the effect isn't the
correct pred merging their goodness only
do a breakdown of what they aren't oh
yes if he could because that's it I
think that's it is a misleading and also
the other thing is in 2013-14 there seem
to be quite a rise in mine compliments
and completely well in completely in
complaints it's dropped back down again
so was there any reason for that I
believe I believe 13-14 was when we did
have some issues with the grounds
maintenance contract and then some the
grass verges they were a number of
complaints that we've received on that
and others picked up coin because they
were quite a lot with service area
charts not done so that we probably
couple yeah it was hot
contracts that was was at the time being
looked at and renewed okay thank you
fine thank you i'll just run stand a bit
more what we were comparing you said
earlier about the complaints these are
complaints with our escalators is that
is that right if I the formal complaints
this is formed by so if someone phones
up and says they're being has a very
empty that's not very registered on here
what is it Richard on yeah it's just
that it wouldn't be if it's a missed bin
your example but then we do log that's a
Miss mean but it doesn't escalate it
through this because to be honest the
person giving the phone and lots of
those are taken up by the fine body man
telephone through customs services and
we do offer obviously we offer people
that they can go through the being
formal complaints process but that's
what we offer them and tell them what
that is for something like a Miss been
we pick out within 24 hours and so the
person at the you know on the phone is
nine times that 10 satisfied that we're
going to do something we're putting this
week of service request so it's log
those miss pings are logged downs and we
didn't know how many they are but that
becomes part of the contract monitoring
so it's up to obviously this is the
director for that area to be monitoring
that's part of the contract and part of
the performance of the contract and
other areas could have similar things
which might be fairly low-level
complaints which people would not wish
to escalate because they would hopefully
be dealt with before the that time yes
that's fine that you don't if I if they
if they then fact that two days major
and said that we failed yeah and we'd
fail to do what said we're going to do
then then we would automatically
escalate that as a
as I completely thought the complaints
are escalated so if with the compliments
how far they are they every compliment
we get there so good cut the compliment
be that the persons not had their being
collected today but then they phone up
to our site off thank you well done you
click my being today with that may be a
compliment I'm fraud against opening and
say every that that is that we've
actually done whatever going to do and I
wouldn't class service at an actual
complement of going and above what you
know ordinarily what we should be doing
that's part of the service that were
before I'd trying to get out is the the
complaint has to be escalated become a
complaint doesn't the compliment we
generally doesn't have to be escalated
to become a compliment so when does a
compliment become a compliment within
these statistics um if it is in fact men
to expand the individual person if it's
about an area that's come over and above
and it does get escalated to the
assistant director to say somebody's
mate you know has got compliments and we
do like to publish those because you
know that that's that that's good but
that we do get compliments and we are
actually very lucky because we do get
the fair amount of what we would add
class as a real a real compliment so we
actually have been very lucky but we do
get those could that be a compliment say
such as I could offer its did a really
good job because I photo that might be
yesterday and it was collected today so
dumb but I wouldn't cast as a comp so it
was no phone service it's a service that
weird but we should be providing in a
normal everyday but you know we do get
countenance about individual people as
they won't open above so it may be an
individual that we like to Venice
callate that through to the assistant
director to their area to society that
that member of self has you know gone
over and above and has received a
compliment but that would be your choice
rather than the comp remain complement
tours of choice I mean again it's it's
it's difficult isn't thank you very much
it's really good to know I would love to
put those down as compliments every time
because I believe we will get quite not
though so but you know camoplast it as a
compliment in here that when somebody
has said oh I'd like that to be
acknowledged to take very much and you
know my second question okay mr.
chairman and mentioned the confidence
that told so the people involved as
accommodated government is targeted to
which is good but is the opposite of
true if anybody complains about staff
set to for instance is a member of staff
told about that as well the fair
attitude these are a pack 2 2day
overhead and so for instance fifty
percent of the complaints are against
one person or whatever it is so you can
yes monitor that yes I mean if it's if
it's about obviously depending on what
that is her series that may be or not be
or whatever no it will be looked at by
an individual it won't be somebody from
that same department for instance so it
will be it will go to a different
assistant director or
or a different line manager if it's
about that member of staff because it's
very difficult to to look at that may be
objectively appeasing around staff so
that will be so depending on the
seriousness of the allegation of the
complaint then it will be looked at
possibly by some somebody else and dealt
with so so yes we you know if it's about
an individual then that gets dealt with
in the correct improper way depending on
the seriousness of the allegations
obviously everything like everything
that we do you'd undertake a review some
of the complaints of compliments sir
focusing all the feedback some of them
are quite complex and complicated some
of the council tax ones that I deal with
sometimes are quite complicated complex
so they take a while to review so you
know the same way we're going to take a
review and we would deal with it
appropriately that members stuff okay
thank you Jacqueline thinking it's a
question really regulate so I mean I'm
very highly complementary ABARES
customer service although very very good
responses columbine about that that's
all the question of what really is is
words as a complaint on a complaint I
write and run out and quality with an
email immediately because simply i do we
talk about the speeds just given the
circumstances and they came down into
the dustbin of completely okay my
husband but they not believe of the best
BTW propylene and it sounds very trivial
but they don't each the lid they damage
the noggin of worried i began have a
dustbin and so on so all i did are
simply contacted the office tom from the
issue very know probably i had a really
nice girl at the other end i was
followed up back with an email extremely
good service and within i don't know
where he was at come home and it's all
men didn't done and everything else now
whatever came back to me and asked me
how i receive the service what my
opinion was when Tina and yeah I would
have been from one to ten I would have
been again and it seems a lost
opportunity yanos meebo there would have
been a lot of
today do you regularly go back on
complaints and check with people that
there or is it automatic or that you
asked with a service usual that is
something we're going to look at part of
the review as you huge opportunity yes I
mean because we do survey people so they
bring foil off don't I ever serve like
people and we got the thumbs up and
thumbs down on our emails with where
people can say is you know good service
or whatever so we have got that mean
things move so quickly now people want
to do things quite quick so we try not
to make survey but that is something
like that a little look at especially
when um possibly get to complain that we
want to pick those and so were you
satisfied with that and that's being
done by somebody else not necessarily
the area where the complaint was and you
know because people do when they make a
complaint no matter how severe that is
they want the issue dealt with and
sometimes they've still believing that
they're quite happy with that but it
would be good for us to go back we need
a compliment a bit further go further
questions go back and just make sure
that we have done it in the correct in
my way that is true but now we find
people just want things i want that very
quick i want it dealt with you know for
me it's not just about our figures and
how we respond but it's good for staff
to know that I appreciate you don't
think that builds morale we internet
needs a better service also and it's
just that flow I just wondered yeah I
think I think don't answer that you'll
be looking at that so we can George and
doing with the customer favorite table
I'm quite impressed with the way the
information has been laid out I think
lot of blue celica seas are variants
information on the data is that I can
see there's increase in decreases
looking at the data but having a Varens
so I would actually make this total bit
more powerful to the naked eye
well I think if Michelle can make a note
of this and then we can pass on to your
doom yeah Jeremy I'm only customer
feedback table the end colin is number
of days taken to sender forward wider in
that in regards to complaints I assumed
it was yes it would be yes and obviously
depending on the Carl Everett bass on
the complaint of policy it says that we
aim to respond to all complaints within
five working days of receipt however
sometimes it does take longer so look at
those figures for the 2014-15 period the
totals the totals there 44-6 and 23
don't add up to the amount of complaint
that we receive so that's i'm just going
to query because there's quite a few
obviously their complaints that are
there haven't been dealt with at all or
fall into another column which would be
ultima they wouldn't put it on Conda
hearing that the one for the number of
dying in the analysis of thing it was
one party it is number of that is yeah
whereas in total for the 2014-15 it
comes to 73 73 complaints without within
these periods of time at the corn here
shows in total there ice tree complaint
Racine so I'm just thinking there's Tim
complains that we received yeah but also
so could you just Beverly because I
noticed that going back yogi is though a
vigil what I don't review before it
doesn't add up to a hundred I enjoy yes
and look back of that and have a
look-see could get going to give us a
nod to turn confusion yeah okay anybody
else why
yeah thank you I think that's back to
the installation issue again however if
I if I complain on behalf of our
resident is that dealt with differently
or would that not get into it because
I'm not necessary Escalades be online
service accounts are Houston ones do it
differently on special understand if I'd
complain maybe how to do sometimes I
raise issues with accounts on behalf of
residence yeah he's not necessary
escalating it I wouldn't be in these
figures no but if it was a complaint of
formal complaint to us then it will go
through this this process and then one
would come back you know we've come back
to you or would ask whether you'd like
us to come back to you or whether
whether you love so not we these are our
councils dealt with any differently took
two residents not from the formal
complaints front of you then so Congress
questions can I just say you're John
Mason sent an email to pull in on the
first give I where he listed a number of
questions which I will read out what is
the council's definition of a complaint
have accounts to staff recognize it
something is a complaint well I think
we've seen in the notes that's been
issued that this aspect has been covered
now as their forwards as far as you're
concerned essentially school well yes
well there's a definition of compounding
the other business is the only
expression of dissatisfaction with a
justified or not as per the FSA blue
line I'm not quite sure the FSIS doing
business or certainly not under that
name anymore but I think you know the
policies is clearly stated by the
council and what constitutes an
expression dissatisfied with a justified
or not
they've quite clearly stated what our
the council's interpretation of these
various aspects are what about cell
phone complaints are they locked well I
you you already answered that for us and
I've heard that only customer services
log complaints is that true then the
answer that is is no so we recover I've
got a few questions here himself don't
know I've carried carried fooled I don't
think they've been covered up so till
now does the portfolio holder get
involved in any of these situations and
if so at what stage as complaints are as
you're doing your review as you say
perhaps it will be cool to label the
portfolio how to be be sitting in in
these meetings in future or are they
currently and we the owner faces feed
information goes to the executive and
the portfolio holder and counseling
Luther skill obviously you know she does
ask the questions about the complaints
certainly to get that information and
now we're going to be breaking that down
a lot more that information will be
there for anybody to to see and to look
at so you know we can provide that
information to to anyone that would like
to see that as well be available to
counselors on request so to speak thank
you okay thank you when we go back to
various complain complainants do we put
in their details regarding their future
options I e on Bootsma is that is that
standard procedure yes
yes it is they will be told that i'm
still not satisfied we can go to the
other words men than they can appeal and
you give them details of the point of
contact time yes is there a statutory
Jamie raise this just now the turnaround
times of these complaints is there a
statutory turnaround time or is it
should we say in a self-imposed one by
the council now we am I mean five days
to respond to them that may not be a
full response because I say sometimes
some of the complaints can be quite
complicated to depend on about but what
the first letter will say is it will get
a given indication of when the
anticipated for response will be so for
example if it's somewhere in my area
then I will be saying to the leadership
support team anticipate that I will
carry out that review and it will take
me two weeks and so that would be time
to the person that's made the complaint
okay and there's put that's pretty
standard you would indicate at the
initial stage if it's not gonna be
answer straight away your time scale is
yes actors are you I don't mind but one
yeah I just when it's coming from the
definition of a complaint of the ex
quite important it does give the
definition of session right here by
things important we recognize it is only
complaint is only complaint if it
selectively experience called directed
by councillors and stuff work etc etc
where it is decided by the replay the
tests escalated through the formal
procedure so they could have a complaint
but they might not be wonderful put it
through the formal procedure clip may
have been dealt with anyway so there's a
sort of two levels of complaint I think
we'll need to revise one of which is in
this report one of the Chisholm which
may go to the service level agreement
and it might be all SAT there and even
might never reach this process these
figures nantes important we know be if
they do if they have a complaint
they're not satisfied then they go go
through the Ombudsman when they know i
think it was understanding make a
complaint which is in our report we have
here is a complaint is escalated to the
formal complaints procedure within the
council yeah only it will ignore it it
doesn't include those complains which
someone doesn't say through that process
they may leave it or they may they may
decide that they're in Chinese going to
be dealt with any way within a couple of
days so it's not so happy for that to be
dealt with in the couple of days and if
you thought we'd open a couple of days
may choose to do that that will not go
through the formal complaint procedure
and therefore we will not see the
figures on here IV asking for when we
record 40 however say that was the
natural difference you can find by
breathing yeah i mean if if the
complainant I mean as you say you guys
are tangled going to join me if if if
the complaint is not dealt with if it's
a grievous ie the dusk is not being
empty then this girl is straight away
then there is no need to escalate it
into a complaint the complaint then
becomes if the service is not for coming
then we're not recognizing in here but
the circus was not forthcoming on that
day but is rectified later understanding
it's not necessary as it says there it
is I can fight to something we transfer
the ball complaint procedure of counsel
misfortune involved no I mean I think we
get to the point oh i think i will be
recognized also nice talking about it or
change it exam sighs we focus on retina
no how you can reflect it to be honest I
think it's important to realize what we
realize it but how do you reflect it how
can you have you do or do you have a
another section this is almost the
complaint I don't know how you can be
flipped wait am I here at the fights the
good fight but it isn't it complied you
just said that it doesn't become a
complaint until is Linda zone I'm said
it doesn't become a compliant in these
figures hmm unless it's a formal
complaint guys where the formal councils
procedure if you phone up playing you're
being has not been emptied that's not a
complaint photo that's not very nice the
best I filippis I'm afraid miss tortoise
is weird or something I only want to
recognize them you might want to you may
not understand it's important to
recognize that in this process and the
figures we have that is not complained
okay yeah i just wanted to resolve the
comment we had before about our figures
on this final page being incorrect then
10 hour I found the discrepancy it's
number of days taken to send a full
reply the second column 6 to 10 days has
been added up incorrectly this should be
should be faulty not for and then it's a
grazing huh thank you much you let say
this they already having you look at
that thank you just to add to cancel or
polite forward and I'm just need to find
out if this this process exists in a
normal business there is a workflow
where you and you can actually measure
power within here in stage 1 2 3 4 5 is
that is that how you measure your
complaint by going through a workflow
and whether the complaint has completed
the 52 mr. voice point it Steffi it got
resolved a point
and then if it's been resolved then you
get a lodgment whether it's being
indebted satisfied satisfactory or not
so I just want to understand if your
process contains of work focus if it
does contain your work but another
statistical table would have to be quite
useful because it will actually break
down this data into understanding what
levels of the work flow has been
accomplished for a complaint ok a
process doesn't encounter that could I
recommend that something always a sub
problem or maybe we can make a
recommendation I mean we get we can ask
you if you wish if we've got it within
the Google this year's schedule for
don't come back give us an update on on
the processes that have been put in
place yeah I mean we know you are new in
imposed so get armies have a bit harsh
on you having to come straight away but
it perhaps later in the year and if we
have we got fitted in in the world
schedule so yeah and we could get an
update on from where you've gone what
you'd learn and take some of these
suggestions that have been highlighted
by my colleagues as to where we could go
or what you feel is appropriate now yeah
yeah I'm it'll do too so first we're
still reviewing the process of it
internally this weekend
you know we don't we can do all sorts of
things we could buy a very elaborate
system that could allow us to do that we
could you know but it's trying to keep
it into context as well of you know how
many of the complaints we do we say we
do deal with them very well we do deal
with and well and we do get good
compliments coming back so I'll just be
thinking that just need to be a little
being careful that we're not making a
system that's that's quite onerous for
something that actually may not be a
massive big problem to us because you
know we seem to be and have dealt with
them and the complaints and the women
and the feedback that we get we do deal
with it very well but it'd be
interesting I think being asked with
breakdowns that they've been asked for
you know looking at whether there's the
complaints are coming from one or two
people that's 10 people or you know with
the same area I think that's quite
important to actually look at the
lessons learned what sort of muzzling
yes sorry about this I understand like
the compliments and the complaints but
looking at this we've also got a column
for comments what is a common as opposed
to being compliment or complaint yeah
haven't got the information in front of
my batteries we put this we see is in
there before yeah 15 and its situation
which ladies
tension from the council or a contractor
such a pro the playground equipment for
suggestions about how to appear service
yeah we can we find yourself full and
and ask dawn to come back to us later in
the year if members are happier you
could you can put forward a
recommendation for a report to come back
to the committee once the internal
review has been completed yeah yes
everybody's happened in that no point
before there we fear no no my great
letter say I think don't come very well
and so you need to answer the questions
that she has berkery if you've got an
ongoing review well let's see what comes
out of that and I was going to get young
just um with the tracking process would
be wise to just pick one sort of field
and then see how useful it and at the
end of the exercise rather than tracking
everything yes yes yeah it's there
anything else we need to pause i'm not a
little for that the recommendations and
result of accept the report with the
with the comments that we've just matin
yeah with the intention that you come
back and see us making the year when
pokin for the end of work programming
you've done your review well thank you
very much indeed you're very welcome to
stay if you if you wish or if you want
to Peter hey
they used to do with the go okay let's
move on to Community Safety Partnership
leaving ladies again I suggest that
everybody has read the report is again
is there any areas that you would like
to draw to our attention or things that
have come to light since we both or
actions that are happening that actually
to elaborate on that you shall mourn
them counties is in your reports or is
that it and we work from that I'm a
similar position to dawn in that we're
doing an internal search of you of my
whole area which is housing
environmental health community safety in
safeguarding so this is report as it
stands again that's liable to change
given in some service review so we
appreciate we have to we have to do with
one of these reviews on an annual basis
so in all with the crime and disorder
act 1998 so we understand that but I
Philippe and I'm guessing a number of my
colleagues would like to ask some
questions on various aspects of this so
who wants to start no go on Jamie
quick question about colonizer now out
on 3.5 talks about performance against
in 2014-15 thorities I'm assuming the
priorities for 2014-15 and 2015-16 have
changed and more happening no they have
but not so overall there is an increase
but it doesn't look huge and with the
exception of one area which is the
shoplifting which is quite a large
increase in terms of percentage so using
name question that data what what
happens then at nebula is a sign they're
all very clearly that there's an
increasing shoplifting crime and we look
at those statistics and then initiates
and projects around that and when I was
in client development manager i sat on
the retail action panel which involved
the large supermarkets across the
district and Lynn suppose you could use
it and they came in with their
shoplifting experiences and one of the
things that was then funded by various
organizations including Rodger District
Council rods the and purchasing of the
life-size cops which did have a big a
big impact on the levels of shoplifting
there was a case where one of those was
actually shocked lifted but if that
things like that did have a big impact
so it is is we just would look at those
quantities lend and create an action
actual turnaround that it's just
interesting to close upon how it working
for me that's what ya mean it isn't
goodness yeah he's quite reactive
because obviously you can't predict
crime nothing so yeah if something like
that does happen we work very closely
with the police in the bottoms of
project or plan to address it any other
question had on looking at with 2015-16
priorities anti-social behaviour is
there a
definition of what's included and then
obviously has quite open bracket of
crime I would say it's a very very broad
remit but I can i can see if i can find
an actual definition i just wanted yeah
i mean some alcohol is that when you say
fur green dwelling private method to you
and love a good things I'm social
perhaps just somewhere before me if we
could just make me happy yeah I can just
say what's included antisocial was
laughing answers or such a queue yeah I
mean that could be anything from cars in
car parks too noisy neighbors too yeah
well rachel is a any purchase the
definition just literally more maybe
it's better than anything else at
something can I just come in to join me
after what I've read this somewhere and
there is a definition of antisocial
behavior this was in the Essex Police
better of the 22nd of jun 2015 which i
think is in members bulletin and i have
their their definition of is being there
they're like it it would fully comply
with all our versions of ASB but it is
there at the bottom of the so be honest
my question is more what's really just a
personal interest really than more than
engine but I'm the kind central may
become my mantra seems awesome thinking
in that is a tradition for nighttime
alcohol time is it no ways with all the
BTW that something else yes fast but
that's how we would treat it if we had
in some noise pollution or possibly
already for policies actually one of
those is quite fast yeah I was quite a
large in the air cross okay Thank You
them Jack do you have something I was
looking at a different they are more
interested to know from cfa perspective
we talked about all the projects and you
know how we're going to tackle these
things baby appears to me that most of
us stood by the police and in fact the
police run project if you like how
involved are the police on you I admire
you I mean hair and that's not really
relevant but have involved are the place
and added a steer this I mean because
when you do look a report to general
books are always love to pass on
information you know they always to
older they haven't got it how do you
focus and target you're more of your
projects you know we're coming that's
the first thing of course it which is
gone today is a crime prevention in your
initiatives and you take or grub and I
short store crime etc Tony attack is
forward in confirmation like it seems to
be a place letting people in if you like
managed by the local authority in terms
of sort of strange relationship it can't
be ripped the grey area because there is
dual responsibilities at times i would
say that we as community safety team
work very closely with the police we
meet them regularly to discuss any
issues that they've got in their
statistics they sent us over monthly
statistics so that we can review them
and then adjust our worksheets
accordingly so i would say we work quite
closely nanogram arranged social
behavior officer does meet regularly
with the other social behavior police
officer to discuss cases or all for
actions that are going on and in terms
of crime prevention there are a number
of initiatives that's the police work on
that we work on them with as well
there's some I don't know
Turnbull's their anti cocaine wipe
square and pub landlords can use them in
if there's any cocaine no traces of
cocaine the wipe actually shows up so
that's actually if someone they wiped
someone before they go into a facility
and if they've got traces of cocaine and
they're not allowed in and so the right
crime prevention things like that in
terms of burglary there's and the is of
it's been around since I was at school
when you used to write on your bike your
postcode there are things like that yeah
there are things like that that the
police drop thing within the home that
we will say publicized as well and offer
so we do work quite closely with the
police but from my perspective I think
we can do a lot more publicity in PR
around for intervention so that's
something that i'll be looking as part
of the internet service review John um
just going back to the shop lift
condemning these figures are meaningless
home because it was
thank you sir you know each other liquor
store has that every single day so
business misleading me yeah and it would
be useful to have information about the
number of shots so you can see how many
have suffered shoplifting that's number
of reported problem how many actually
reports it that something that we did
really work on and encourage people to
report and when I was an economic
development really encourage businesses
to do that and that was a reporting did
increase for that something that we need
to continue where as a peak if people
don't report it then well actually we
take so sure and yeah it's going back to
the data 3.5 with the community
committed to community chapel by the
place base you this booklet which gives
us a lot of statistics but shoplifting
and a lot of other categories it is that
Peter way you're basing your information
from is it because this book would split
it's going to broken down by area
downtown and by ward and I'm just
wondering like to media sixty-eight
percent in chocolate I don't know
exactly where those those that can be
that can be broken down into two into
what our parishes and wards and now that
information is already present in the
PCC database if it be useful to send
that round that I'm certainly happy to
do so because I think that will be very
useful yeah
and it's broken up into the whole
Rochford district area our fingers three
years three simple areas and that that
data and their compares with the be in
your position right now to the same
position the year before and and also it
also describes the in incidents on a map
as well and quickly so if you like up
and I've got some electronic versions to
illustrate butter in it from a CSP
perspective either because you've got
that partnership with the PCC take your
piece of PCC shooter these sergeants
should actually pass that information
over to you today may well parts are
able to grind Brown I think they do it
by dae emc they send away all the ten
being a document regularly but when it's
an early when there's a clown on 12 this
is a natural a summary of what's
happening in the last quarter in in the
ward in a different world like coffee
all areas and look at the hospital you
know that doctor i'm doing that don't do
anymore george i know this we have
discerned that meeting yeah they toss
that don't anymore they usually have
researchers in the police station
they've done away to them what was the
book which i received from their
community meeting which replaced the
next meeting has got that information
they did have up until last night I last
ones fears started last one that's what
we were told and that meeting last month
I know what I'm saying is in the new
bleating that they've reformatted the
booklet but it's not the same as than
that a boat still slightly to with any
information given a lot of ways to get
our nut meeting yeah they caught bad
people
see what you can do I am yeah I would
see what what is these folks coming yeah
what would go Johnny I've got one more
person which I wasn't missing from
raising it more than you and regards to
funding cause him there's not a lot
essentially during every financial year
is there's two elements to it from I
gather this is the future properties for
instance the 2015-2016 and money needs
to be spent on those priorities but then
there's also the using dangerous
statistics from the year before and
responding to those for example mr.
Chilton initiatives with that funding
cannot only be used on the future
initiatives what can that be used on so
for instance the funding here we're
looking out for the year april marches
17,000 provocative council we've listed
our priorities for this year but then
we're looking at the statistics from the
previous year and shoplifting possibly
as a result of those statistics some
money is going to have to be spent on
initiative can that is that 17,000 that
use above yes where the priorities are
the very similar to the lungs of a set
of previous year so a lot of projects
will simply continue right but where
some of the priorities are quite forward
there is potential to initiate projects
around that so our actions and project
titles are quite broad as well because
then that gives the freedom to be
reactive so if there is for example
missing burglary or an increase in
domestic violence or any recent
shoplifting we have got some sort of
flexibility over how we spend that money
on so
why you hang other complications i'll
keep to the first area and starving
which is probably about partnership
working my understanding both of you has
landed yourself a new into the router
south by a user to have the full grasp
per year paris the partnership working
on interested in I recognize some of
these issues from the youth stretch food
group which I'll sit on obviously around
the youth area as it as it were so
healthy relationships things like that
how if you're all we're now how did you
see or how can you see the CSP working
more closely with new structures we good
for instance the new strategy we've also
get funding well now you're not seen in
the first meeting attended and somebody
that's feedback fry the chair exhaustion
has aligned yourself do so as DSP Zekrom
corrects a chair not primarily well I
should be chairing the youth strategy
group as yes it's like a metal just
being to meeting yeah the next what does
it tell you and you're on the CSP as
well essentially yes so that's where the
joy that should come from subtly
have you thought about pulling the grant
money to some extent is that something
you've got through your mind it's never
happened before I think it might have
been an idea floating around so that
where if there's a something that around
the health relationships that you've
specially rigged things involved in the
CSP thinks it's important could they
fifty-fifty funded for instance is our
possibility to get two main three times
something better rather than do it
individually which seems sort of
happened in the home I have to admit I
that's the first year such a group i
attended and it was my first thought
alcon why I have two groups working on
things at the link I'm had me in the
shape projects together so I need to
meet with julie from as its kind to
counsel to look at how we can actually
do that so I've seen the schedule of the
funding strategy I haven't looked at it
in detail and I don't know if there's
anything that crosses over but I take
the point in my career it's something
that you should work together with
various common area cuz ya doesn't be
able to use it across somehow thank you
it's going that also crosses I've been
to the area of safeguarding as well
we're talking at closely in particularly
in terms of healthy relationship without
sex exploitation making young adults
more aware of what is domestic violence
what is sexual exploitation so crosses
over into that so does it's also cross
on over onto a forget that I right bone
chill children's advisory boards or not
cuz I set off one of those as well
sadness expose you to another Church of
dumb surfaces grow food is the local one
LBX bump operative
cheers children services it's because I
wear that such as commenting on those
they have your cell will want to append
pulse with beef domestic violence for
instance and always wonder how these do
everyone doing things separately but
they're not they could be a little
little bit more driven yeah numbers
tension na le Europe from now on because
everyone is leaving us in some form and
how it might affect affect we recently
attended the Essex children safeguarding
board meeting a couple of weeks ago now
it's one of the key things that was
addressed at that meeting how we can
write together Nassau everybody there
for Michael Authority social workers
health workers schools and how we can
work together cuz room eating the same
issues from initiating projects but
let's do it together and then leading on
from that pulled my hair wheel this one
and the last between meeting whether
it's ESP time which remain at that time
we've been own castle Macpherson
residence there was talk of it was a
community hospitals here at legislation
and remaining things that happened it
hasn't happened the data agreement it's
an information sharing agreement cuz
i've seen a lot what the police do is
very confident on a lot of what we did
community is very confidential so we had
to have a data sharing agreement which
and went through legal process and draw
that up and get both parties to agree
that has been agreed once that was
agreed we're now going through the
vetting process from the police to allow
non elite officers to go into the
building which can take up to three
months once that has gone through them
we can locate offices in the building
say it's regressing then just one more
move it on so different area and you've
got kobe veins which community older
persons event on no means an expert in
this is my understanding a bit more
possible with the is there's two
sicilies to show that i would equal more
likely to be burned or is it something
that's
easier to reach them there's a lot about
cope events here and there's a little
bit about crucial crew which one on our
a townhouse has done this is although
there was having district-wide again
which is young people old older people
have specific events here so as what I'm
asking is how to measure the
effectiveness of those events without
producing what they're supposed to for
troops are you reaching people are
always he really easy to reach as the
policies are now in the fire service
they've stopped doing general events and
such and presidential then reach the
right any more than the people
vulnerable or them or neither to having
fires in that case I'm just wondering if
the coke events reach fun origin right
people did every the people who have got
the save Gotham has already oil anything
out or because mmm are they do they need
to go and visit these people rather than
have them come to them sorry person I
think of events are working very well
for how they set up and who they're
intended to reach whether they get to a
point where they overreach those same
people who is a different issue and
because they are being held in different
venues each time being invited people
are from different residences like
they're only from sheltered
accommodation there is always a limit to
how many people can attend depending on
the size of the venue the occasion
issues you fertilize funded by one else
usually mon the local stores the process
of the event that i have been to one is
one of sort of the people be invited
people sills around their own table and
those that are there presenting very
safety initiatives are moving round
every 15-20 minutes so they're very
specifically directed I know eight ten
different receptors and formal aspects
from the fire service and police from
social workers know various aspects of
safety it's not just about crime but yes
I mean there is an issue about where do
we go with that and how do we reach more
people that probably are in more need
than some of those who do attend but we
haven't got to that point yet no that
will come out as part of the service of
you I thinking about them Jay thank you
I went to have have you been in quite
with a short of the wall ago with Helen
and it was absolutely amazing it was
really good I thought it was actually I
know knowledge is it really compliments
any really no point which one ours was
we get funding for the BCC right for all
these initiatives but they send it be
please let this the impression our game
they seem to be orientated valent police
you know and I'm interested to know is
how the money's managed on terms of life
who are the hearing room who or how is
it decided on what initiatives and how
much to each initiative is it's actually
allocate has its all formulated we set
our priorities that are generally in
line with our district statistics and
close that one PCC PCC degree those that
give us our funding we then set out an
action plan which details projects
initiatives we're running how much
you're spending on each and how they
meet those priorities that's then sent
to the PCC for greet Minh so we set out
what we want to do we want to spend
money and then they agree then at the
end of each year we have to go back
there action plan this is what we did
this is impact that they have this is
how we measured it this is how we spent
the money so they actually get evidence
that we've spent the money in the
correct way and we've actually made a
difference of what we've done so I have
a community safety if you like
environment is controlled by pccc did
not have publicly we've got a very much
flexibility of the projects that we run
as long as we can prove that they're
meeting our priorities so notice I asked
if you cook Atacama I'll few questions
on this funding issue we're Amanda ship
with Castle Point so you have a bigger
percentage of the joint pot the window
how is this calculated and if issues
changed during the current year for
circumstances beyond what the district
councils control or castle point ie the
issues that are now currently affecting
rightly is there any way that some of
these monies can be restructured into
different projects okay the allocation
of funding is based on thirty percent of
its based on Ares population thirty
percent is based on areas level of
deprivation and forty percent is based
on open crime rate in area so that's how
it's worked out and its new way of doing
as for this year in terms of
reallocating funding I think we get our
set funding for a year that is agreed by
the PCC as I've just said with the
action plan and if for example nighttime
issues in rayleigh came to the fore that
would already be covered under
antisocial behavior but i would imagine
we would go to the PCC and explain the
situation say can we change the action
plan I will go back to cry and cry
and if that is the way that we would do
it but it's routine to me before it
let's be continuing an action plan that
is ignoring a problem that's just come
up so i will go back to crime and double
check whether we can change the action
plan with agreement with PCC Thank You
Jordan come on thank you um CCTV many
councils have reduced their coverage at
first I have been doing much for
district I'd don't need a virtual disick
answer don't control any CC novela I
mean there's town counts on parish
councils overall throughout the whole of
this year have been any reduction in
CCTV it's not be amazing for me as far
as I know no one's mentioned anything to
me I will go back and ask the safety
team if they've heard anything but it's
not been my definition attending the
town comes yeah I can answer some of
that for you joined yes there has been a
reduction in the flexibility of some of
the cameras purely because it wasn't
being used and the capacity by the
police that we hoped it would be so that
River ventilation yes yeah we don't know
that that was the initial stars as June
said then we walked into an issues with
Ripper which Jacqueline light you on if
you've got a couple of hours but we
found that although we had these
facilities and yes to a degree it didn't
detect act as a deterrent the number of
times of the police actually came in and
asked us to feedback was minimal they
were really at the site being called by
various other means than actually
looking at CCTV it was used historically
i think you will also find that
with licensing now they have taken a far
different attitude towards clubs and
pubs and there is CCTV all over the pubs
are the doorways and all this sort of
stuff is quite dictatorial as to what
they must have if you see these
licensing applications go through it is
quite specific on what they want the
standards of of camera work that they
need it's all all there so to a large
extent it has taken away some of the
needs that we needed within the district
not circle within with him Riley okay 13
come we can ask the question of parishes
and see yes yes please here Rob would
rather than point Thank You Sharon and
for my own information I'd like to know
a little bit more about the reasons to
why we are in partnership with counsel
point in respect of this and if we
guards to the point 3 11 you tell us
about that there's three officers
involved in this we do play then do one
of the castle point or they feel me no
it's purely much of it neither our
officers elected with Rockford issues
and cos appoint officers will only deal
with house appointed she's waiting who
is a reason why were in partnership with
I don't know the history behind that but
and I would imagine it's just we suffer
in the face of the demographic and we
have to say from them areas though I was
looking frozen oily yeah I can answer
that I was some chair of the city of
here at the time when it was discussed
and although we were reluctant going
with class or quite there are a number
of meetings where we would have certain
different people sitting on the CSP and
work from other organizations that were
having to go to the castle point one and
then come to the south end ones and it
was actually a waste of their time
having
bath so it was agreed that provided we
kept our individual officers in our
individual areas then the CSP would be a
jump on it was it was he couldn't have
people from the fire brigade having to
go to all these other different meetings
and it's okay konica dares to happens in
this and it's still valid at the reason
why I think that yes I me nothing let's
go back to cap appears searches why it
was then combined last yeah because the
idea was to keep the officers Rockford
officer so that we ensured we had a big
something the most revealing it has I
mean if it was reviewed by the review
committee going through that process of
joining into one Mon cher I've got my
nice charity committee I think you're
right you I think we are obliged by law
you have our own offices irrespective of
living at you in partnership with castle
point we have to have our own and for us
as officers it's quite useful to go to
the joint meeting because we find out
about the initiatives at being run in
and castle point and any issues that
they may be having been affect us
particularly in terms of burglary which
happened in can be and then came to
rally so big wedding or wherever it's
it's useful from my perspective azure
and local authorities have there any
member representational Jerry personally
I think possibly a few people going to
be able to answer to Leslie over i'll
just go say was that understand the
reasons for that especially because to
having people turn up above and now
you've set up see it was screech out of
either of you can see before I'm
assuming it is no financial difference
between whether Google with can sort of
fold up reviewed it we didn't think you
wanted to stand hardship I'll take our
funding on fourteen thousand will be the
same irrespective well
I think there used to be a larger public
funds for climate disordered in bed yeah
and that back got reduced over the years
another reason for joining together my
ethical gym I just wanted to understand
a little bit more around the current
situation regarding the team of three
officers which is short lead only one of
yourself on a streamer as we are lacking
the London 20 safety system protease
bacon which is 26 24 type of them and
the Community Safety Officer domestic
abuse is going to shortly be fakin
obviously yo mess up security says that
at 3.12 and discussions are starting
with Essex please in what way to Essex
Police have an influence on our staff
does that mean that they might say we'd
only different bunch of safety assistant
or I'm particularly concerned around the
and the domestic abuse position for
instance I think it's more about how we
use the funding that we have to cover
the service and whether that is done
through a member of staff whether it's
comes through buying that somehow else
JD yeah I can expand on that obviously
there is a team of three people
currently well currently two but seem to
be one rather than just replaced the
jobs like for like I'm I started
conversations with Essex Police over
what should our priorities bean doesn't
make a difference to domestic violence
levels by us having a domestic violence
officer dedicated to that bowler would
it make more sense to us to have to
commute safety officers covering various
areas so is to me it's I've got three
offices what are those officers best
suited doing what's the most efficient
use of our funding and so that's why
those conversations with Essex Police
does it actually make a difference
having domestic violence days an officer
and in terms of her absence we do have
housing office of the covers domestic
violence in relation to housing so we
have got that domestic violence va voom
contact there and I've also had a hand
over in the cooler today and ask that
everyone involved in j9 or keep safe
project that they are emailed or
notified to contact safeguarding if
anyone does come into the venue say I
need help I've got dementia or I'm at
risk of domestic violence in speaks
someone said that they can email or
phone into a safeguarding officer which
is myself with safeguarding officer and
then we're going to be somebody there to
deal with it because I don't want it to
be the situation that Paula's no longer
in place their housing tumescent housing
domestic violence agent offset is in a
meeting that person phones up has
finally got the nerve to say on being
domestic APA's there's no one to contact
them and I personal contacts us again
it's one chance for all I don't want to
miss that one chance say they were to
someone there to be contacted say and
they would always have training in the
area or honor being trained in later I'd
really i'd say me we don't have time to
talk about it much but not specifically
domestically no but we would we would
some we would ya we would be able to get
some advice and give them as ours and
say to me we would then maybe befriends
buzzard and domestic violence Outreach
Center who are obviously trained in
Appin offer advice or somewhere to go
that's a new place it
yeah yeah it's a new place icon Nelson
Jane thank you holding the last cover
just about coming on their bike or
question Oh on domestic violence I
thinks it's usually because having a
spoke specifically contact officer is
essential because sometimes in the most
divisive provide experiences it comes up
as a very minor little crack and they
say that one opportunity and they're
very vulnerable people involved so i
think is probably the most important
thing that we could ever do anyway a
compliment in there but the thing is
that what I was gonna ask was it was
mentioned earlier it was about the SS
matches the most of the messaging system
hair evolving in there because now we
measure it because on monday sounds or
so I Monday and I know quite a lot of
what goes on in this area forever linked
and they don't reflect on the messages
okay so question really about that is a
vision and then we monitor our can we
ensure that system is really effective
and doing what it's supposed to do I
mean a neighbor a number my two doors
like a broken into I know there and I
was never a message about it there was a
suspect no mr. Johnny so what I'm saying
is that all update is it is that
effectiveness and hourly important that
its equator more than anything if it can
be looked at yeah my doesn't they'll
take that way yeah okay ladies and
gentlemen everyone if there's no more
questions snow will fall has got
provisional date for and CPS to come
back in business again later in the year
subject to the work requirements if
there's nothing else this evening will
close this section of our meeting now
and review if we if we would like our
guest to come back in later in the year
when they've done their review and and
worked our new systems that they may
think we should be told about yeah
I'll leave you put it to the oath with
cheering Jody and take it from there
thank you very much indeed thank you
like a thousand no no no thank you
see this weekend sometime or just
consistently series successful August oh
pretty released establish a tix
emotional if you just do it in her area
no it's so two doctors office area thank
you weeks later yeah there are we
rockford hook what we need for all sales
operation can earn an average I put only
no subside yeah the suit las cosas
bonitas quite honest I downside
my injury so I'm getting a bit confused
so we're not to ask the question again
well that wasn't what we were told that
the last night meeting the community
meeting which know about your family
where do you want to call ready yeah
whatever they call it yeah I think the
next meeting anyway thanks that George
has confusion should we go for guys come
back fragments line right like young
petite decision documents item 1 15 i
think we discussed this on made our
feedings node and felt at the last
meeting about chinese commercial
charging for the car parts and also i
think at the same time we made our views
or waiting or in subsequent report on
the social housing allocation scheme
when we meet to that the last meeting
the other two areas at this stage i
think we're just waiting for so this
information to come forward onto meebo
you know we've all the harm strategy the
date is moved it was originally june
it's now going to be set temper and
that's because it's a service review
that Jodi mentioned taking any time
housing community and everything else so
after that there will be a review of the
home strategy hmm anything to add on to
750 and sort all the charges now I
expected that report of coming by now
bail it's obviously been delayed the
same documents as I mentioned it last
month just allocation plan off the area
acting banging cetera it's just really
good the charge for printing knows I'm
going on to 815 with regard to the waste
local plan Paul has done some research
on our behalf and can highlight two
potential sites that have been but the
loss the wording here a search area
encompasses a particular area within
which a suitable waste management
facility could be delivered as opposed
to a direct sight allocation that
represents the exact outline of where
the facility is considerably suitable
the process of a type identify the areas
of search has been focused on employment
land within the industrialist a zip
across the plain area it goes on the
attention of these areas of search to
act as a guide for waste operators
seeking to develop the site within the
plan area should waste development be
proposed site allocations not come
forward application made within these
areas of search will still be required
for planning application which would
need to contain precise details of the
proposal that is in a non-technical
summary that paul hasn't discovered
forests thank you very much the two
areas that have been mentioned in this
district are aviation way industrial
estate emissions farm
but of course I think we're all pretty
much aware nobody quite knows what's
going to happen be Michelin's farm but
there we are thank you for that forward
serif anybody wants to read it and
that's available publicly on the county
website is not the NC document or
anything like that it's our consultation
and current time in any member of the
public can log on their comment magic
boxes his first of a smooth type
situation or is it for recycling yo
gotti got that whatever you say so what
I are they don't really clarified I in
when I started planning they were going
on about don't dust enclosed waste
facilities if you need any more details
you will need to speak to Natalie hybrid
implant and she's quite happy to learn
about Charlie dr. wash management began
to get better not be how you would react
in uvalde tub see if you got any queries
but we as a district council we can have
to put in our response to the
consultation partner these integers are
20 that's like encompass self at Borough
Council as well that the waste disposal
site this strategy document does but
those two sites on anything to do out
there
aviation why and sutton road the
relatively close to each other here but
there are different boundaries i know
that yeah I mean yeah I got there
understands got their own sites listed
on their humanity in procedure manage
boys yes I realize that yeah but they'd
still be geographically quite close
Anglin compared to the one but we've
already had this conversation whereby
people in the used to the district can
move our five miles to a recycling site
in south ends as opposed to coming to
Reagan which is a 26-mile round round
trip Association we're making you aware
of what what is currently the situation
where we go from here I don't think
anybody knows at this stage the thing
that I do as much more centrally based
off about the district isn't it as
opposed logic technology be right I know
what I think you're looking that's
probably the most suitable site in the
east of the district as a post mrs.
phone which is for the west of the
district anything else no turkey do have
my fall yeah but so please see the
information is available with you going
to it any further we'll go on my porch
or just one for the work programs get it
but near about times and okay
the next meeting will be on the ACT
September and we've lined up some health
experts for you and they're going to do
the changes that they made due to the
Social Care Act we have Kevin
commissioning as in town council of
Public Health the county head of
commissioning of vulnerable people and
then we've got the accountable officer
of the castle point of Oxford's ccg to
come along and the chairman of the
castle one point and Rockford health and
well-being board which is Terry come off
but we've got more to come along with
Tom permits about Social Care Act and
they're just going to brief you about
the changes that have come about because
of that I'm going to open it up to other
members and we going to hold them they
turned down in the chamber because i
think this one there will be a lot of
interest from other members talking to
some of our older they've already said
they will be interested those are the
reflected by do we knew they feel some
beeping or work so you know i think that
will take everything i don't think
you'll get anything else at that minty
promised by the dreams during planning
forum um sounds of getting the most out
of a number of people coming i'm hoping
that i won't have copies of the
presentations before the meeting they'll
be able that you don't have so you'll be
in a look at those and
any questions then parted similar to
what we thought we've done here mine are
you going to reform their you can read
it and then ask them to elaborate on any
specific points or generate any
questions okay and six of October I've
got ripped up penciled in hopefully
laughter before for that at the time
next week more than 40 years eve jordan
effort they are versatile so there's
going to be a few other bits of company
yeah then if we look at the 14th to do
knowing that's the first one of the task
and finish groups treasury management
annual review and those that put their
names down George Jamie dunno yeah
Robbie everything garry's mod another
excuse da joy step down okay now
additional work items being considered
and programmed in a later stage I'll
stop the chairman and vice-chairman of
already circulating to you various
reports about planning enforcement and I
say in that email looking for volunteers
to form a project team for that one down
I'll go in there anybody else that once
they did that one do so again climbing
important move the angles now I brought
to you interesting we're being in
meeting so here I'm sticking out if
after about a long-term everyone kind of
London he'll be very much another one
now if you know the one flash oh you
make sure went oh yes and there's only
three Church of management one survey
year and if you notice the really got
july in November is the next training
management and then January the anarchic
treasury management little trophies and
the phone your folks are more than that
would that be a similar number of
meeting cynical and yeah probably it is
probably take about three meetings or so
you put me down yeah the most like one
class with no that's fine with the Li
tribal I'll make sure there goes that
prep we are going to go to back in Danny
no now I once I know who's and we're
going to do it overall then start
arranging we have been major if I want
to do is is chairing a money or but
really once opposed to the moment yeah
I'm feeling to be filled yeah yeah yeah
everyone okay um right the budget
process and consultation
think there's the ntfs report catching
this down the budget process and various
bits relating to that that's went out to
today yeah i should point out that it
said that estimates will come to review
committee in december it won't it will
come in February long last year that was
a mistake and I've already pulled it out
to them okay and if there is anything
else on the budget process you want to
review and now is the time to mention it
I've done nothing fancy like that I
always had an issue i SPECT i speaking
to teeth the time when he was doing with
spaciously when the budget book tours
open spaces IE parks and recreation with
that fitting for what you're talking
about there none hey no because that's a
society that's a specific budget right
this is about the actual process and
consultation but I vou if you've got a
specific budget you've got an issue with
that should we don't remember away days
okay
right so if there is nothing on that one
then all cross it off everybody's happy
okay and planning conditions and scheme
of delegation if I can link up with the
plane pro too cold and building control
will be where we currently have it all
we've advertised and will shortly be
interviewed for an assistant director of
planning and what I would propose is to
let that Officer get appointed and then
arranged for him to busby come to the
October or November meeting to discuss
those three topics gained from that
possibly other reviews will come out of
it but to start with to get their
feelings about those three areas so you
can buy me I hope to be on at me I'm
just combining C and G C
okay working with other authorities the
new IDs have been carrying out various
service reviews and I'm sure that will
be some ideas about working with other
authorities from that my suggestion
leave it on the work plan at the current
time oh wait to see what comes out again
later on all right potholes again well
it was a long-running issue last year I
think just leave it on there and come
back to it at a mighty strange and the
commander stand for some of us went to a
meeting hosted by V Johnson County all
the other day we politics find it to
some of the roadie counselors but
basically Duncan friendly Bros changes
in rochford district over the next year
or so they prioritize on roads one and
two most of our roads I think fall under
category that comes under either estates
or rural and you know I'm sorry wait a
minute will ya we've raised a number of
issues about we go wider Huddle's kitten
with holes keep sinking in major roads
how many times up to go back within a
year before they work out that probably
is more to it than just but you know the
whole senarios basically we do it a
pretty good job with better than we were
but you know we are getting there but
accepted that certainly areas like that
for example had not had the best of
surface for six or seven years ah well
hey i'm going to change overnight i
personally i disagree i think and the
amount of the roadworks round our area
so greatly increased her proper hockley
obviously and that sort of area and i
think i personally believe it is going
great that's my new bed I've never seen
so many we so much work being done in
our area so we must take you to some
other areas well poverty and when you
can send in my area office I represent
my hair bible they this was as an
overview well there was probably 50
counselors there across the whole of the
county and by large most of them were
saying pretty much the same as us but I
told you the priorities they told you
how it would work and that yes they are
aware of these other areas and they will
get to them but not in the chills
obviously down to bronze county
councillor Paul could I of course is
this appropriate time to it's just
another item via to this list but Adam
can we get to the end of this year and
then you can n okay okay homelessness
and council's housing strategy again
I'll go back to the service review
that's been mended by Jodie I would
suggest that we book it in through
October we forget the come
and talk about the service review and
how it's affected going to damage
already have work because she's quite
happy to do that so that's sort of
sitting quite nice again okay the
revisit of the third party software
review i would suggest putting mr. one
then about this hand council smells
official now I love that him in hundreds
of sorry August oh yes because you know
they're all rounder that review and yet
we visit the third party software review
I would suggest that possibly comes to
the meeting in December because that
would be about a year from the last time
just to see what savings that managed to
to get over the year from that one and
in finally richlands farm now talking to
the chairman of vice chairman we think
that that possibly should be done as a
whole committee and we arranged for the
various people to come the Bears
committee me I'll arrange extra
committee negative if needed to go
through Trivium use the string to
reemphasize like [ __ ] governments of
the encounter because obviously not
everybody is familiar to vanish then
with Mitchell in farm and we have a
great asset that it was drilled all of
us yeah yeah I think I mean this is
making sure we don't we can use that
that's not problem just meetings farm
being put forward as well as the
preferred waste areas have an effect on
this should we be looking at in an okay
I think we got what we can look at i
think is important is historically
what ways on absolutely that's it we
can't start predicting what will happen
in the future what causes of action
might be technology this is a
retrospective look at what got us to the
position we currently find ourselves if
you go into what what you have to do
with it and everything actions it
becomes pmc because otherwise you're
tying your hands someone by letting
everybody know I know I know originally
I was one of each in his farm because I
here I feel that as a council we've got
why I like to know from what happened
there what didn't happen there and I
think that is very useful for the
residents as well yeah I never say I
think we need when we talk about this is
pulse-jet see we need to be quite
specific this is a [ __ ] retrospective
historical view of what happened to why
we've ended up where we have but as he
said we can't go anticipating what will
happen in the future yeah I just
wondered whether the fact that you've
been portfolios and prefer concoction
that it's going to affect we would be
doing and then we come on to hang on
Sokka took me home just quickly about
mature its farm I think they're thinking
about altering the roadway only a 12 45
and I don't know if any of the land will
be purchased compulsory can't got that
picture future we are that's what we're
going to quite specific here what's
happened up to mail and the fact that
the railway line store
because of the song can't they don't see
what led up to the car in the farm now
that I always feted it in by highways
because I've got something sort of
cornered but a lot of residents with
regards to reviewing me the speed limits
within within the district as I said
that it's mum consistent or inconsistent
inconsistent I'm just wondering if is
that is that something which we can
actually review and take on board the
hills would be very handy terrible on
the outside too I understand I think
he's counted as my self-imposed track
record trying to get somebody from
highways from County is as a zero they
might actually talked about Jess if you
want soft from County on a white dress
councillor Howard right now we here
comes local Highway pedals that is quite
willing to come to me to his look at you
to do is not a fabric memory I'm saying
that it must be worth well okay yeah you
know but I mean I rather long as I mins
left yet but he's got me more willing to
talk about it and he's waiting to move
traffic glass as well I think remember
I was dealing with an officer and
Matthew Valentine is we've done I don't
know these are we that went to use
replacement dagger and it's very
confused it is a complex ish or impotent
and obviously it's not bashing okay we
were very confident great speller quick
Tara yeah I way to email some joke
though I'm two things should be merciful
on the planning enforcement something
I'm happy gonna take a look florals
quite interesting I think nothing they
certainly are no I'm going to
reemphasize it because I did raise it a
lot on about needs and then followed in
their last meeting you certainly know
man so all members did you get able to
come back to you no no first I still
think it's something that we should see
that more if I once again small as a
priority at the moment than you think
landscape don't hope you say something
back yes it was a very bold from the
tread new strategy group because they
obviously does it needs to some extent
would that be a starting point certainly
yeah i mean if we've got some long to
talk about it is darling which would be
pushing me Jody's bridgett lee caps i
love it or whether we're going to show
you i'm doing closely with mark elders
are DC we actually we received a grant
funding from the lindsay white house and
to you to actually support use and part
of the money is there to provide a login
you wanna get go on into some management
within fishing but that's death starting
in a couple of months time so but
there's a partnership there's a
partnership with the PCC our DC and
which is my girls Osmond yeah okay so I
women are they develop originally you
tamales de I think it wasn't so much
anything specific like that it was
literally looking at the council and how
we are prepared to do nothing a lot of
young people if I know lots when people
are guided to contact people like
account Citizens Advice Bureau been
stopped in that I don't quite know what
I want to do where they can go schools
and other people kind of into mom comes
out of Council or no help you and I
think you will actually I don't imagine
if the council wall fits like to do
basically we have corner connections
within the scope come in and talk to the
children where they're going and what
they're doing and that an apprenticeship
something I just can't think the council
could act like more than central point
people assistants told them declare an
interest here on the connections work
yeah other cam cartels question albicans
are the best people to do this no no I'm
also degree qualified quiz advisor as
well when we do go into the schools and
I work for South in Council but we also
we are but we have been brought in by a
number of Essex schools because Essex
connections were disbanded
so we go into certain in school we're in
King Edmonds greens would Swain and Fitz
so we get we're in all the all our
Rochford schools as careers advisors
they're the people the schools are
responsible for that needs a noun with a
change in the law they now actually the
school should be tracking and they
should be responsible to know where
their young people succeed a gum tree
because they should be in educational
training till the age of 18 but you try
and enforce that so many thing because
that people have is the fact that people
family the benefits so be reduced but
there is telephone contact that there is
still a team in Essex that people can
contact and there are still people that
can help and you know Roger district
schools partnership trust and the
children's tamers as well you know they
they're able to do things for young
people but all those all the senior
schools have connections workers from
our team in South End yeah film
ambassador but we had we actually goes
far as possible yeah which schooling old
dell sale yeah we're in the air itself
yeah I ally of the regular you know to
see our children yeah I know nice and
Catherine Catherine
whether mean what happened these
connections just disbanded in Essex hmm
we in Southend for how long a good
business hammer we retained the team got
all the team even hire qualified than
anywhere probably in the country and
then sold our services to Essex oh it's
instead of having their own team of just
walk us in so show me this is some pop
disappointed nothing you know we've got
unavailable counseled fronted for
injuring district council whose
committee of doing a similar thing would
in a vault or I think for us to sit
you're gonna go no we're not the best
people to do it are we offering any
apprenticeships for young people I don't
think we are all except fine work I mean
if we want to call in but we you know
are we going to come in and get this
answer are we going to get well we're
going to get into to ivory this little
Barrett there there are there are too
many there's not enough work being done
with younger people like that totally
agree but that bet they're the people
that are doing the information and
advice within schools and the help and
then people will do it in school that
there isn't quite right if a young
person from Rochford contacts us an ass
yo they've led school their college
course hasn't worked out right bait
often will phone us and ask us and for
some help them can we wake up we're
going it can we asked Paul to do some
digging it's coming back to the
connections to me to do in Essex let
Paul do some digging on these power and
come back with some recommendations to
us well there is a gap yeah what do is
our I'll circulate round
and counsel and I need anybody that is
dealing with needs etc and try and get
some information from okay you and then
see what involved and they've got IE
mark orders etc and then yeah I'll come
at you well thank you I think you give
the phone numbers and everything of the
elite team that is meant to be
responsible but they are only at the end
of a telephone that's their 16 and
that's bias is not good enough w my
mouth as well okay come on thank you sir
are here again cutting down I personally
think that customers want Samaritan this
I think just because knowing i think
perhaps because nobody's doing this some
extent as overall view of what's going
on i think it has some we're eating din
looked at by us there's no reason why we
can't choose to these accounts or
whether or not it's the within the remit
of the review which to look at it and
then say we should be doing I don't know
I like funny you say I think you you
know we we've said we do it homework
we'll come back we'll come back with
some answers as to what they do in the
name thank you and I also certainly say
that there is a gap in service
requirement but are we the ones to put
it all how the we fill it not once you
know thanks i like the recommended
amounts get get soon yeah somewhere else
yep okay yo it's not just purely council
business usually perhaps it's a play or
short by our service integer so i think
that's a derby I should be this
respecting human dress but I mean in
your link
yeah that's it okay do something else
police thank you very much